[Music]
Facebook stock resumes trading today
after suffering the largest one-day loss
of any publicly traded company in
history shares of the social media giant
plunged nearly 20 percent yesterday that
erased about a hundred and twenty
billion dollars of Facebook's market
value bianna golodryga is here with how
some shareholders say co-founder and CEO
Mark Zuckerberg he's part of the problem
yawning good morning good morning it was
its worst trading day since its IPO in
2012 and once a darling of Wall Street
Facebook has long been one of the
markets best performing tech stocks but
with its announcement this week that the
company's growth may be slowing after an
avalanche of scandals it's becoming
apparent Facebook's prosperity isn't
guaranteed big news has become
increasingly maddeningly disturbingly
popular especially on Facebook for
months Facebook's headlines have had
trouble getting likes Facebook is where
that all the action is spent and where
all the problems and it's not just this
issue with Cambridge analytical scandals
involving misinformation and data misuse
thrust the company into damage control
from now on Facebook will do more to
keep you safe and protect your privacy
the social media giant pledged to
resolve the issues through television
ads and top management in the entire
company is focused we're adding over
10,000 people we're using technology to
help us find bad actors and bad behavior
I say this gently your User Agreement
sucks on Capitol Hill in April lawmakers
questioned whether CEO Mark Zuckerberg
was doing enough to correct the course
prompting an apology we didn't take a
broad enough view of our responsibility
and that was a big mistake and it was my
mistake and I'm sorry the turbulence
caught up to Facebook on Thursday when a
mixed earnings report for some investors
to dump shares of the company
controversies have been from a lack of
good controls in place investor Matthew
passkey is CEO of Trillium asset
management which owns Facebook shares on
behalf of its clients he's critical of
Facebook's leadership structure and says
Zuckerberg needs to reduce his role our
next ask
of that of Facebook and their board is
the separation of chair and CEO but
wired editor-in-chief and CBS News
contributor Nicholas Thompson sees no
signs of Zuckerberg giving up his power
if the stock keeps going down and down
then pressure could come as a crabber
but again I don't think he'll be forced
out and speaking of Mark Zuckerberg he
personally lost nearly 16 billion
dollars in yesterday's slide now that's
enough money to buy some of the most
expensive major league baseball teams
including the Yankees the Dodgers the
Cubs and the Red Sox combined
he's now estimated to be the sixth
richest person in the world falling from
third so no one's really feeling sorry
for him from a financial perspective
this morning we're not finished hearing
from the company though testifying
before Congress Sheryl Sandberg the CEO
is expected to testify for the Senate
Intelligence Committee in September he's
under the gun no question but I would
think this would only make him work
harder for the company that he started
yeah yeah no I think he will fix it
thank you bianna